I I went to dinner one night at a
restaurant and Stephen Soderberg was
sitting with a couple friends at the
table over never met him in my life and
he got up left and I'm with my wife
we're eating and the waiter comes over
and goes Stephen Soderberg paid for your
meal I said what someone had pay I was
like what and there was a little
note from Steven Soderberg saying
whatever and I was like what the
and so I thought oh man he wants to
work with me man or something you know I
should send him flowers or something so
we call his office the next day and he's
like we're like day he you know like I
was super that was so sweet can I send
flowers or something and they're like no
he does it for
everybody he does it all the time he
buys people dinner left oh God why'd you
say that